welcome to this special edition of
Hannity I'm Jason chaitz in for Sean
tonight I hope you all had a very Happy
Thanksgiving well today as part of a
4-day pause in fighting between Israel
and Hamas 24 hostages including 13
Israelis have been released from Gaza
remember these hostages have been held
in Gaza since the Hamas attacks back on
October 7th and after today's release
240 host ages still reportedly remain
captive in Gaza with an estimated 10
Americans among them here now with the
latest on the ground in Israel is our
very own Jeff Paul
Jeff yeah good evening Jason and we are
learning tonight that on top of the 13
people who were released today we're
expecting maybe another 13 could come
out tomorrow but I got to tell you here
on the ground in Israel the mood is
Bittersweet mentioning sort of what you
were just saying that there's more than
200 people who are still being held
captive in Gaza but today was a huge and
crucial first step and if this current
ceasefire that went into effect at 7:00
a.m. on Friday continues we could start
seeing more and more people coming out
now here's what we know about what
happened today uh according to Israeli
intelligence they say 24 hostages were
released by Hamas 13 of them were
Israelis 11 of them were foreign
Nationals now among the Israelis who
were freed we know that four of them
were kids ages ranging from 2 years old
to 9 years old the 99-year-old uh child
actually had his birthday while he was
in Gaza being held cap captive by Hamas
now three of those people were mothers
six of them elderly women none of them
were among the Americans that were in
were that were being held in there not
at least yet now today Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu spoke about
the hostage release saying that he is
working on to make sure that everyone is
eventually sent
home I emphasize to you the families and
to you the citizens of Israel we are
committed to the return of all our abues
this is one of the goals of the war and
we are committed to achieving all the
goals of the
war now we know that Israeli officials
have a list of the names of the people
who they are expecting to be be released
tomorrow but they have said throughout
this entire process nothing is
guaranteed until it happens local media
here on the ground in Israel saying that
among the people who are released
tomorrow they think maybe as many as
eight kids could be released we're
hoping that ceasefire holds and as long
as it does we're hoping to see more
people be released
Jason Jeff uh amazing reporting thank
you stay safe out there we appreciate it
all right joining us now with reaction
is Dory Roberts who family members were
among those released from Hamas
captivity today and former State
Department spokesperson Morgan oras
thank you both uh Dory it's got to be a
Bittersweet day uh I can't imagine the
emotions that are going through um what
you're feeling but to have at least
three of your relatives come home safe
that's got to be good but you also had
an aunt I I believe who was killed um in
in this terror
attack oh thank you so much Jason for
having me on the show tonight and good
to see you again Morgan I know we we
were on this show before and uh it was
very emotional day back then and it's a
very emotional Day from a whole
different reason today we're very happy
to receive our uh family members back
home they're in the uh hospital right
now uh going through uh medical exams uh
We join with their family uh it's been a
very very emotional Day to all of us to
seeing our our hostages unfortunately my
aunt frat Cuts was uh murdered and her
body was left by the Gaza border um she
was murdered in front of her uh daughter
donon cat who is now back in
Israel um and we are very very happy to
uh for those news today we that we have
a lot of questions that are still need
to be answered um were there uh alone
how they been treated where they had any
contact with other hostages we still
have about 218 hostages left uh in the
Gaza Strip held by the Hamas uh so we
taking this period of time right now to
rejoice and reunited with our families
and our loved ones we're very happy for
all those families and all those
families who received the loved on uh
but our goal and our mission is still
stay focused and uh keep our actions and
our Miss
ahead is to bring everybody home safe
all of the 218 left in Gaza Strip back
home to our families to Israel and to
call this as a complete mission to say
that everybody are back home with their
family with their loved ones for the
holidays this is what we're about to do
so we take this time to to be happy but
we still have a lot of grief we lost
almost 14 100 Liv on October 7th we now
try to rebuild the ones who survived and
bring those back to the life they had
before October
7th and and Dory before we go to Morgan
tell me about your aunt she was murdered
in front of family members on that
attack but tell me about her what will
you remember most about
her my aunt project was very sweet uh
you can see from the picture that she
loved nature she loved travels she grew
up on the kibuts her entire life and
community and family was born and raised
on the kibuts she was a very sweet and
kind very
Noble who always found time and
attention to give to her kids and her
and to us the family uh she held us
always close and she was a sweet sweet
person that I always remember her Gentle
Touch and her capturing smile her deep
eyes and and her beautiful hair was
always something that I remember from
her and she's now uh resting peace right
next to my mom's grave that that's where
we met last time about three and a half
months ago when she was there to support
me as we uh lay down my my mom and I
will never forget that moment right now
she's buried right next to her and we
are praying that yeah we'll be able to
rejoin and bring our family together
once again uh and hopefully this time to
celebrate and not to
grief well fortunately your your cousin
and those two um young children ages
four and two uh are back and safe and
they've went through some trauma that I
can't even imagine and and Morgan I I
want to talk to you about the look
you're mom uh but you're also uh worked
uh at the state department um and so I
want to kind of talk about the
significance of what this is happening
what this is doing what this signifies
at the Diplomatic level because there is
no equivalency in
kidnapping a 2-year-old and a
four-year-old and and in murdering more
than 1300 people um and what's going on
today in this in this hostage uh release
it's
just it's just beyond fathom well on
what's happening on the emotional level
but on the Diplomatic level what are you
seeing
well I I couldn't agree with you more
and and Dory I just want to say that my
heart uh just rejoices for you and your
family uh to have uh to have them back
the mother the two girls I I I thought
about you guys so much as our VI viewers
here on Hannity will remember um it was
just a few days after the war whenever
you and I were both on Hannity and and
at that point I I had actually been in
the Middle East I was headed to Israel I
could not get in and I had sort of been
in put myself in you know war zone
morgage
um and I had not allowed myself to to to
grieve or to think about it and I had a
2-year-old who actually just turned
three a few weeks ago and when I saw
those pictures of your nieces and and
your cousin and your family uh that
night on Hannity my heart just broke and
I have to tell you Dory that I have not
forgotten about them and I promised you
on that night that we would pray for
your family that we would fight for your
family and that we would do everything
that we could to help get those little
girls back and I got to tell you I was
furiously checking the news today to see
who was going to be released who was
going to get out and the moment that I
saw the graphic and saw the pictures uh
of of your cousins of your nieces that
those two little girls those beautiful
little girls were being released uh I I
just I just my heart just leapt for Joy
I I was so happy for your family so
emotional for your family but as you
said and and I'm totally with you on
this you know we think of the other
children you know there's an American
little girl who I believe just turned
four in captivity who who is still being
held uh hostage by by these uh just
these these awful brutal terrorists so
we we Rejoice for the family members who
who were able to get out today um we
pray because we know that it will be a
very very long recovery ahead mentally
and physically I'm sure for them um but
you know the president this
Administration they cannot let their
foot off the gas pedal they must
continue to pressure uh Hamas Qatar
whomever it takes uh to now get the
Americans home and to get every hostage
uh that we can home but but Dory I just
felt like you and I shared such a
special moment early on in the war and
and there was times that I I'll be quite
honest that I didn't know if you were
going to get them back but I I kept
praying kept hoping kept believing and
I'm just so thrilled for you and your
family
today Dory Roberts and uh Morgan oras
thank you for your perspective really do
appreciate it hey Sean Hannah here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else